معرض النحو الفضاء والذي تم انشاؤه من قبل
الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء في يوم يتزامن مع
اطلاق
الصاروخ انطلاق رائدي الفضاء الى المحطه
وكاله الفضاء الدوليه طبعا هذا المعرض يضم
القطع التي يستخدمها رائدي الفضاء وكذلك
القطع ايضا التي سوف يتجه اليها رائدي
الفضاء وايضا بعض المعلومات عن
انطلاق رحله رائدي الفضاء حتى وصولهما
وايضا عودتهما ان شاء الله سالمين عموما
هذا المعرض سوف يحكي الينا في وبيتفاصيله
المستشار في هيئه الفضاء السعودية الدكتور
هيثم التويج مرحبا بك دكتور يعني نشاهد
قطع ومعلومات عن
عن القطع التي سوف يستخدمها الرائديه
الفضاء وهي يعني قطع لاول مره في هذا
المرض في وقت يتزامن وجود ثلاث معارض في
ثلاث مناطق سعوديه سلمك الله اول قطعه
نتكلم عنها اللي هي نموذج لمركبه اللي راح
يستخدمها رائد الفضاء للوصول الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه وهي عباره عن قطعتين
القطعه العلويه اللي هي الكبسوله وين يكون
فيه رواد الفضاء والقطعه السفليه هذا اللي
هو سيرفس
على الهد وهو راح يكون تواجد
بمقعد داخلي مقعد داخلي الاربعه اربع رواد
فقط هي في اربع مقاعد في
مساعدتك وفي مقعد للاخصائيين ريانه علي ان
شاء الله
ايضا هناك الزي الخاص فيهم يعني يشاهد
الزي اللي راح يرتديه الفضاء ريانه وعلي
طبعا البدله هذه بدله فضائيه هذه تعتبر
البدله اللي يستخدمونها رواد الفضاء في
تواجدهم في
المركبه الفضائيه وكذلك لما يكون يتواجدون
على محطه الفضاء الدوليه بينما هذه غير
مؤهله انها يسمحون فيها في الفضاء انما
هذه تعتبر احدى البدله التي يتم استخدامها
يعني هناك عده بدلات يعني يستخدمها على
حسب يعني هل رائد الفضاء راح ياخذ تجربه
السباحه في الفضاء او الخروجه اللي يسمونه
او فقط راح يكون متواجدين في محطه الفضاء
وروادنا ان شاء الله راح يكونون متواجدين
في محطه الفضاء
دكتور يعني نشوف هنا روبوت مختلف هل هذا
الروبوت سوف يتم استخدامها من ريانه او
علي لا هذا سلم الله نموذج عن
الروضه موجوده الان على سطح المريخ
واحد من اثنين كوريا
وفي الواقع الحجم هذا لا يمثل حجمها
الحقيقي نعم
طيب عندنا مجموعه من الصواريخ طبعا برضو
اشكال من الصواريخ دائما نتحدث واحد تلو
الاخر عن اذا تعطينا معلومات عن هذه
الصواريخ هل هذا الصاروخ الذي سوف يصعد
عليه ريانه علي لا هذا بالنسبه للنموذج
اللي امامنا هذا
الصاروخت هذا اللي يستخدم في الستينات وفي
الاضاءه للسبعينات للذهاب للقمر نعم ماذا
عن الصاروخ الثاني في الجانب هذا الصاروخ
الاخر هذا النموذج اخر صاروخ قاعده تجهز
وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه ناسا ويعتبر يسمى
اللي هو
الجديد اللي راح يستخدم كذلك في مهمات
الذهاب للقمر و برنامج ارتمس اذا هذا
الصاروخ لراي اليه الفضاء ريان وعلي نعم
هذا نعم هذا الفاكن هذا من شركه سبيس اكس
وزي ما تشوف عباره عن قطعتين القطعه
الاولى هذه تعود للارض وبعدين القطعه
العلويه هذه اللي يكون فيها الكبسوله
والرواد الفضاء شكرا لك دكتور هيثم اذا
هذه المعلومات التي اوضحها الدكتور هيثم
التويجري وهو مستشار هيئه الفضاء السعودي
والذي اوضحها لانواع الصواريخ والمجسمات
وكذلك البدء التي سوف يرتديها ريانه وعلي
وكذلك القطعه التي سوف يصعد عليها ريانه
علي اثناء انطلاقهم مساء هذا اليوم في
تمام الساعه العاشره ونصف مساء بتوقيت
المحلي السعودي اذهب الى فلوريدا الى مفرد
العربيه حسين الطودة حسين مرحبا بك
بانتظار ساعه الانطلاق هذا اليوم ما الذي
يحدث الان هل انتهت كل الاستعدادات
تحيه لك خالد وهاني نحن الان بالقرب من
مركز كندي للفضاء ننتظر دخولنا الى المركز
بعد نحو ساعه تقريبا بالنسبه لرائدي
الفضاء ريان وعلي لقد اكمل الاستعدادات
النهائيه البارحه اليوم بعد حوالي تقريبا
ثلاث ساعات على الساعه الثانيه عشره
والنصف بتوقيت فلوريدا سيصيل الفريق
الفريق مهمه اي اكس اثنان ومعهم ريانه
وعلي عبر مروحيه الى مركز كندي حيث سيخرجا
من المروحيه ويلوحان لاهاليهم ولاصدقائهم
وعلى الساعه الواحده والربع تقريبا سيستلم
فريق سبيس اكس هذا الفريق فريق رواد
الفضاء لاجراء التحضيرات النهائيه عمليه
الاطلاق ستكون طبعا على الساعه الخامسه
ونصف بالتوقيت المحلي بالنسبه للصاروخ كما
شرح وتفضل الزملاء
الرياض هو يتكون من جزئين الجزء الاول هو
الكبسوله دراغون والجزء الثاني هو صاروخ
فالكون بالنسبه لدراجون هي اول مركبه
فضائيه خاصه لنقل البشر الى المحطه
الفضائيه وبالنسبه للجزء الثاني فهيتك
يتكون من قسمين او بطبيعه الحال القسم
الاول هو القسم الاكبر ويتضمن تسعه محركات
كبيره والقسم الثاني يتكون من محرك واحد
عندما ينطلق هذا الصاروخ سينفصل عندما يصل
الى عشره اضعاف سرعه الصوت تقريبا على
ارتفاع 80 كم سينفصل الجزء الاول ثم يبدا
القسم الثاني بالمحرك القسم الثاني بالعمل
حتى يضع المركبه في مدار معين فوق الارض
قبل ان ينفصل هو بعد ذلك بعد نحو ثمانيه
دقائق لتسبح هذه المركبه وتاخذ عمليه
الالتحام
المحطه الدوليه نحو تقريبا 16 ساعه حتى
تخفف السرعه طبعا الرواد الجريان كما قلنا
الاستعدادات انهوها البارحه
هناك عندما يصلون الى المحطه الدوليه
سيجري الفريق السعودي 14 تجربه علميه
تتعلق بالجاذبيه وتاثيرها الجاذبيه على
الاعضاء البشريه وتجارب علميه اخرى
بعد ذلك حسب ما فهمنا سيبقون هناك نحو
اسبوع قبل رحله العوده الى الارض
هنا حسب ما لاحظنا في وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه هناك تغطيه لهذا الموضوع هناك
اهتمام كون ريانه هي اول رائده فضاء عربيه
وسعوديه تذهب الى الفضاء وتلتحق بالمحطه
الدولي الدوليه هذا له اهميه ينظر اليه
هنا على هذا الامر
كما قلنا ما زلنا ننتظر الدخول الى مركز
سندي حيث سنكون اقرب من الصاروخ ويمكننا
الحصول على صور اكثر دقه من هو عليه الان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات